une autre conséquence aussi on l'a vu ça
t la critique où il a été un révélateur
en fait des systèmes qui fonctionnait
bien ou moins bien qui est sur le
plafonnement des prix de médicaments
puisque les industries de la santé oms
des coûts de production d'un médicament
ont des coûts de recherche d'innovation
et donc il faut ensuite payer ses coûts
par la vente du médicament or comme le
budget de le budget de la sécu et et
focaliser uniquement sur les coûts il
fixe le prix du médicament non pas en
fonction de ce que ça coûte à produire
mais en fonction de ce que ça va limiter
en matière de dépenses et une des
raisons pour lesquelles on a vu partir
des années 2015 et ça s'est accéléré
début des années 2020
2019 2020 une délocalisation des usines
de production des médicaments c'était en
réalité pour faire baisser les coûts de
production de manière à pouvoir limiter
la baisse du prix des médicaments alors
après on s'en est plaint en dix ans on a
perdu à savoir faire industriel on a
perdu une partie de la chaîne de
production ce qui est vrai mais bien se
rendre compte que le budget de la sécu
étant focalisé uniquement sur la
limitation du prix on est en train de
détruire cette industrie du médicament
dont on s'est rendu compte qu'elle est
extrêmement importante et elle est en
plus sales extrêmement complexe parce
qu'on voit souvent les grands rôles et
les fans et les entreprises phares comme
sanofi ou d'autres il ya tout un réseau
de pme qui vivent aussi de ça et donc
quand on pense la santé il faut penser
aux les infirmières les médecins
généralistes les spécialistes mais aussi
toute cette industrie de fabrication des
prothèses des bases de médicaments de
l'ensemble même des dés ce qui permet de
prendre fin deux flacons qui permet de
tenir le vaccin et ça c'est tout un
écosystème qui est de plus en plus
bringuebalant par le fait qu' on a
larchitecture qui est en train de
s'effriter
[Musique]